In Israel, it is now the turn of the teenagers.
Anyone over 16 can now get a coronavirus jab,...
...cementing the country's status as the world's fastest inoculator against COVID-19.
4.25 million people have now received at least one dose of the vaccine.
That's nearly half of Israel's population.
Among the over 60s, that figure rises to 80 percent.
And in yet, more good news for Israel;...
...studies show the brand of vaccine being used is highly effective.
One dose of the Pfizer Biontech jab provides 85 percent protection against infection...
...and two doses offer a whopping 95 percent.
Israel reportedly paid about 23 euros per single dose,...
...compared with 10 euros each by the EU.